ever had a freshly cooked steak
delivered straight from the
International Space Station let me tell
you it's not going to be what you expect
you must have so many questions right
now like is it possible to fry a steak
in space how long would it take to get
that perfect crust and what side dish
should you go with hmm solid unlock for
Kayla this is what if and here's what
would happen if you dropped a steak from
the International Space Station it's not
every day that a chunk of meat falls
from the sky astronauts on the
International Space Station have
precautions in place to keep anything
from dropping down to earth but at the
same time they have to deal with
spacesuit gloves that only allow about
20% of their gloveless range of motion
and sometimes things do slip away
astronauts have dropped everything from
a camera to a spatula they used that
thing for Space Shuttle repairs and not
for cooking in case you're wondering so
what if you got to go to the ISS and on
your final spacewalk a perfect cut of
ribeye steak slipped through your hands
completely by accident
all right before we get to the part
where your spacewalking with a piece of
raw meat in your hands we need to figure
out how to get that meat there in the
first place the International Space
Station has been continuously occupied
since the end of the year 2000 but none
of its visitors have been chefs
astronauts have all their food precooked
here on earth their meals either come
ready to eat or can be easily prepared
adding water by heating anything that
hadn't been approved six months before
your launch would be prohibited you
would break about 20 food regulations by
sneaking raw meat aboard the ISS let
alone by dropping that meat from orbit
there is a reason why dropping objects
from the space station is a no-go and
requires astronauts to report such
incidents immediately but let me get
back to that in a moment the ISS is
orbiting 400 kilometers above the earth
what do you say we start the experiment
with some closer to earth cooking as a
side note I'll eliminate some of the
orbital effects from the story for now
let's imagine that the steak you dropped
would head straight down to the ground
what would make it cook
when an item like a steak is plummeting
to earth from space it moves really fast
and because of that high speed the air
in front of it can't get out of the way
fast enough it gets compressed and when
air is compressed its molecules move
faster releasing kinetic energies things
get hotter but would it get hot enough
to fry the steak well let's see if you
drop the steak from a height of 70
kilometers it would break the sound
barrier for about a minute the air
around it would heat up to 177 degrees
if you've ever cooked a steak you know
that this time and temperature isn't
quite enough to cook the meat all the
way through when the steak hits the
ground it would still be far from
well-done at 100 kilometers up your
ribeye would be falling at twice the
speed of sound for 90 seconds that's
enough to add a little cooked crispness
to its surface
unfortunately you'd still be eating raw
steak thanks to the sub-zero
temperatures of the Earth's stratosphere
dropping a steak down from 250
kilometers above earth would get at that
lovely seared surface the falling meat
would travel at six times the speed of
sound although it would still end up raw
on the inside if the steak fell from
even higher above the atmosphere its
front shock wave would have temperatures
reaching thousands of degrees the meat
surface layer would start to burn off
looking more like flakes of carbon
rather than
nice medium-rare steak but even dropping
the steak from the ISS wouldn't give it
enough time to cook through you'd be
eating a burned lump of protein that's
raw red in the center on earth it
actually takes some degree of talent to
cook a steak like that if you take away
the burning part space makes for a
horrible barbecue unless you prefer your
steak raw with an ashy aftertaste you'd
also have to wait quite some time for a
steak to reach a plate if the ISS itself
were to fall from space it would take
two and a half years due to the orbit
it's in exactly how long it would take a
steak to freefall from a height of four
hundred kilometers is uncertain in
reality if we turn the orbital forces
back on your steak wouldn't actually
make it to earth your potential dinner
would go into orbit first then roughly
90 minutes later it would be flying
right back at the ISS at a speed of
roughly 28,000 kilometers per hour it
might not hit the ISS but if it did
you'd know it right away
red meats bad enough for you on earth
but in space it has the potential to
wipe out an entire crew if you're still
up for the experiment at least remember
to sterilize the meat before you seal it
in a pouch and don't take cabbage beans
or broccoli for a side dish those foods
make astronauts fart and that's never a
good thing in close quarters the only
escape from that stinky situation will
be taking a walk in outer space
maybe with no spacesuit at all but
that's a story for another what if
you
[Music]